our next speaker is Michael Nelson
he's come from Oregon State University
he's also the co-founder and co-director
of the conservation ethics group and the
title of his talk is at the intersection
of wonder power and worry
thanks to this opportunity it's
wonderful to trade the Jerry West for
this injury East so when I think about
experiences or questions about gene
editing I'm typically in the realm of
conservation should we the extinct the
passenger pigeon or the ivory-billed
woodpecker should be genetically altered
tree species or Salman it's so that they
better endure the impacts of climate
change should we edit rhinos so that
they don't grow horns and become targets
for poachers those are the kinds of
questions I'm interested in and I'm a
philosopher or an ethicist by training
so I think a lot about arguments
actually I think it's probably fair to
say that I worry about arguments I just
really fair to say I worry a lot I grew
up in the Midwest so worried is in my my
bones and it's in my vocabulary no hole
jeez it's like this and I'm a professor
so I have a position description that
looks a lot like everybody else's
position description but it has this one
one addition to it which I realize adds
up to over a hundred percent but I'm not
a mathematician so I'm going to honor my
my contractual obligation to worry
publicly and I'm going to just share
some of the worries that I have about
this amazing technological possibility
and I'm just going to share five
different words I have more than this
but I'll just share five I'll take it
easy
so the first worry I have with any of
these kinds of conversations is what
I'll call the de stunted conversation
worried this is the worry that we will
pretend that we can decide whether or
not we ought to employ something like
gene editing these technologies and
conservation without do reflection most
commonly this comes in the form of the
assumption that just because we can do
something
that we ought to do it the assumption
that can in fact implies odds now it's
obviously the case that you suggest
somebody ought to do something they
should be able to so odd implies ken but
it doesn't go the other way around and
when I say it like that I'm sure your
responses will duh that's so obvious
that just because you can do something
doesn't mean that you should do it it
may be obvious but we do this all the
time in conservation I deal with people
who do this constantly in conservation
jump from Kendall art or just are bad at
thinking their way through what we can
do or what the truth of the matter is to
what we ought to do so I hear all the
time I work a lot in the in the wolf
realm and I hear all the time that we
can hunt we can trophy hunt wolves
without negatively impacting their
overall populations
therefore what's wrong with it we should
hunt wolves that's a very common and
actually very effective refrain from
state wildlife agencies and it's a total
violation of ethical common-sense which
doesn't stop them at all so my worry is
that we'll just we're going to do this
again we're going to we're going to fail
to draw upon the full power and force of
the human imagination contained in our
various disciplines and in the world's
cultures and worldviews as we think our
way through this but my worry is a
little bit alleviated so far because
we've already accomplished a little bit
of this here we haven't just pretended
that if we collect the right scientists
together that we'll figure out what we
ought to do so we we know this we've
accomplished a little business maybe it
might be too early maybe a - at this
point but we could we can improve so I
want to I want to dwell on this a little
bit just just as a way to get us a way
to think about this if we want an
argument that has like as its conclusion
anything that is prescriptive right any
can or should we have - this is not just
a matter of inclusion this is as real
matter of logic we have - as a matter of
logic have two kinds of premises
descriptive premises about the way the
world is or the world way the world
might be but also normative ethical
premises about what we value
how we think the world ought to be so
it's only by bringing these together
that we can arrive at this conclusion so
when I hear things like the FDA says you
have to do science and then you'll know
what to do logic doesn't work that way
and that's not me that's Aristotle so if
you have a problem with that that's what
you have a problem with another way to
think about this is just this little fun
infographic I mean if you want to answer
that last question you have to bring in
the humanities that's that's the realm
so the second problem or the second
worry that I have is what I'll call the
horse poop pick her up or worry and I'll
illustrate this with a story of my
friend this is my friend and colleague
Mary Beth Lee she's from microbiologist
from University Alaska she's also a
musician and a dancer and her research
involves microbes and plants and
bioremediation cleaning up oil spills
cleaning up playgrounds at schools that
are contaminated by by diesel fuel
that's the kind of work that she does
and she's really worried about that work
she's worried that her work as a
remediate is good and important in fact
we should clean up our messes that's
what restorative justice tells us we
should do but it's also used as an
excuse by those who would despoil those
properties in the first place it's an
excuse to continue the desolation she's
worried about being an enabler or an
apologist for the forces in the world
that are bringing ruin and harm in the
first place
so we could call this the apologists
worry perhaps the worry that so much of
what we do in the realm of conservation
is equivalent of the person at the back
of the parade scooping up the horse poop
a propping up the continuation of the
parade making the continuation of all
this madness possible in the first place
so that second wear is very much related
to the third one the do we understand
our real problem worry of course
conservation is absolutely a
technological a technological issue
absolutely we need new technologies
desperately and of course it's an
ecological issue we need to do
ecological science
it's a social science issue we're
starting to realize certainly and it's
an economic issue of course but most
fundamentally I would suggest it's
actually a moral issue it's a
conversation about how we ought to live
in the world so I worry perhaps actually
most of all about the belief that
somehow we're going to tinker or
technologized
our way out of our current mess our real
problems it seems like our problems are
actually more fundamental than that
fundamentally it's a bad relationship is
a world and it's hard to understand how
new technologies alone are going to
remedy a bad relationship for the world
it's actually easy to understand how
they in fact could perpetuate it so part
of our conversation about editing nature
I would suggest needs to also be about
editing our relationship with nature
so the fourth worry and I'll make this
one brief is the what I'll call the
calculation worry it's actually a set of
worries in that that is once again we're
going to be bad calculators of the costs
and benefits of anything but of course
with these new technologies so even if
we assume that simply considering costs
and benefits is the right way to
contemplate the use of these new
technologies even if that's how we think
we should make our decisions about this
which is a dubious assumption to begin
with and some have even argued that's a
dangerous assumption there's more to the
world and considering costs and benefits
but even if we assume that's how we're
going to do it we need to recognize that
we're not always very good calculators
and that there's a reason that we're not
very good calculators in general if when
the cost-benefit analyst is actually the
beneficiary in any way whatsoever even
if that's precision and promotion at our
universities there's a strong tendency
to overestimate the benefits and
underestimate the costs social
psychologists have showed us this over
and over again so what does accurate
assessment of costs and benefits
actually require of us how do we do this
when we do this well what are we doing
what qualities are we manifesting when
we do this well
well one might argue that the accurate
assessment of cost requires empathy a
lot of empathy and the accurate
assessment of benefit requires a great
amount of humility checking yourself for
not for not benefiting neither trait
Embassy nor humility is acquired without
effort and neither trait is at risk of
overabundance at our institutions
so my final worry is this come up a
little bit in our conversations so far
and this is what I'll call the who
decides worry and I think about the
words of Aldo Leopold immediately when I
think about this and I think about this
quotation from Leopold II said we and I
think of what might be called the
standard paradox the 20th century our
tools are better than we are
and grow faster better grow better
faster than we do they suffice to crack
the atom to command the tides but they
do not suffice for the oldest task in
human history to live on a piece of land
without spoiling it so this was 70 years
ago Leopold warned us about this to sort
of check ourselves a little bit again
he's warning about the tools of the
technologies not being all that is
required of us but he's worried too
about our abilities to apply those tools
decisions about gene editing or
conservation triage or assisted
migration or intervention in wild areas
to secure continued land health in the
face of climate change or all of the
many very serious conservation
challenges that we all face are enormous
ly difficult they are sad and they are
serious tragic no-win quality they have
no in qualities to them so that reality
that we face
I think suggests that we need certain
kinds of deciders certain kinds of
people who make decisions in the face of
that future certain people with certain
kinds of qualities so I teach a class
called conservation ethics and at the
end of each term I ask my students this
question I say so you know we've
discussed these challenges we know the
qualities of the future that we face so
given the
Normandy of the challenges the sad
seriousness of those decisions who would
you trust to make such decisions and I
don't mean people I mean what are the
qualities or the virtues in people that
you would demand for people to make
those decisions and obviously when you
ask a question like that even though
I've had them for a whole term there's
this awkwardness this awkward pause
because they're not used to being asked
questions like that but slowly they
start to give answers I say envision a
person that you think you would trust
and what other why do you trust them
what are the qualities that they
manifest and so slowly once the the dam
is breached it starts to flood slowly
the the chalkboard starts to look like
this they start to mention all of all of
these virtues I would expect a person to
be all of these things and this is not a
thing well it's empirical in the sense
that I'm taken from my students but it's
not quantified in any way but the ones
that are larger the ones that they that
they mentioned more and the one that
they mentioned most of all but they
cringe to use this word so I make them
use this word is they insist that the
person who gets to make decisions about
something's well-being has to love that
thing they'll fight like mad not to use
that word which is funny in itself
actually they squirm so then I then I
ask them to think about people who are
currently in positions that make these
kinds of decisions people that they know
who work for agencies or at universities
or wherever in politics and I say do you
think those people manifest those
qualities and the students immediately
shake their head and they laugh and then
I ask them to reflect upon their
education and I say you know do you
think your education is focused upon the
manifestation of these qualities that
you've identified as so important to the
future and again they shake their heads
but they don't laugh very much at that
point some of them actually want their
money back
so our problems suggest that we we
desperately need thoughtful wise humble
respectful deeply attempted empathetic
caring deciders and as a professor it's
not obvious to me that this is currently
the focus of natural resource education
at all nor the focus of training and
natural resource management policy so
how do we do that how do we create a
generation of wise deciders how do we
create deciders that can thoughtfully
and wisely navigate the future that is
before us so while we sometimes offer as
a kind of concert a conversation stop or
comments like well who is it that gets
to decide I think that's a really
important question I don't think we
should offer it as a conversation
stopper it's a starter I think we should
take it as a live question and say yeah
who does get to decide and not think
about individual people but think about
what makes an appropriate decider in
this future that we that we face what
does it mean to be a good decider how do
we become them or how do we how do we
craft them I was trying to think of an
alternative name for this and trying to
think about people that I knew that
manifest these qualities and all I could
think of is Dumbledore and and so you
could call this oh my God all the
stumbled or is not a real person
worried so if we had a whole world of
Dumbledore's maybe but I worry that
we're not really focused on this and I
think it's a it's an imaginative
challenge for us but I think it's a
really it's really a worthy challenge
and I will stop there
you
[Music]